[Music]
oh I'll put that I'll put that all those
in favor aye
contrary to clear a character cheerful
oh it's okay well we'll start the young
utilities and Rohde
committee meetings we got any apologies
for Mindy she might be a wee bit like
cheese but they assigning to do so and
she won't be too far away
hopefully just from some staff by the
look of it would be helpful connected at
some point so yes cheering running a
little late okay so we'll carry on any
conflicts of interest okay you want me
to move weenies apology mr. Chiu yes
silly thing to do with it so you live
digging it all on paper all right all
right
okay okay we've got any conflicts of
interest of anything no ok so
confirmation of limits held on Tuesday
the 17th of March we're going to move
there
they moved Oh Robbie we've got a
seconder second al all in favor all
right
hey we got any myths rising from the
minutes yes yes counselors here yes I
just wanted to ask about the major the
merge abatement plane that was there as
in the recommendation last time there
wasn't a timeline on it is there any
update on when when it's going to be
forthcoming I haven't had enough and I
don't think there's any staff here at
the stage to give us a date so hold that
question until one of our staff join us
I can who do you want I'm sorry I've
they're all in the waiting room do you
want me to get them all to join yes yes
you've got Jared in particular but yes
probably I'm not sure how many you've
got here but yes they could join
[Music]
actually Kelly might be there was an
indication on that question
Kelly was just asked about midges and
the last them minutes have you got an
update on the midges nothing like
hitting a phone away oh yeah can you
hear us Kelly I use Paul I can hear you
yeah we had councillor Stewart asked
just specifically the midge the merge
plan that time given was talking about
this um going to update there was no
timeline for it and while it's winter
and I
what what the procedure for that was all
about yeah that's my understanding staff
are still working on that preparing it
for effectively next summer so yeah when
we don't have the issues with midges at
the moment like we were experiencing
over the previous summer so danezaa
status of that effectively preparing for
next summer showing this report seeking
approval for the recommended scheme
design and cross section for flexed and
road between Southport Road and
Kingsford Smith Drive South brought a
previous report to the council January
annual plan budget meeting providing
some options for piping of the drain
along flex turn road the cost estimate
presented to carry out this work was
three point three five million dollars
less approximately 2.5 million of that
being the piping in 800,000 being the
extra roadworks that would be required
it that meeting approval was given to
proceed with the scheme design but
piping of the drain was discounted
due to the ecological and cost concerns
around it
in the meantime staff have continued to
work to ensure that we are optimizing
the road layout and have been developing
a recommended scheme design which
largely retains the eastern curb line
and incorporates a two point five meter
wide she'd path along the western side
of the road there
lay out would result in the loss of car
parking along the western side of the
road which equates to approximately 60
car parks and retains around 31 car
parks on the eastern side of the road at
the northern end so nearest McDonald's
we the highest
on street parking demand currently
exists the proposed layout plans have
been sent to daniel smith is a major
land holder in their area for comment
and he is supportive of the recommended
design he has requested two specific
areas of no stopping and that's really
just to help accommodate those larger
turning vehicles coming in out of the
track stop the current cost estimate for
the recommended design is around forty
six thousand dollars over the budget
however that does include a 15 percent
contingency so there's no extra budget
being requested at this time we would go
out to tinder and see what our tinder
prices bring finally just a note that
the safety audit sorry safety audit
needs to be carried out on the scheme
design prior to the detailed design
being undertaken and this may result in
some minor changes something
incorporated into the detailed design if
there are any larger or significant
changes then we would report this back
to you an hour I'm happy to take any
questions any questions - questions can
you confirm there's a handrail in the
preferred design is there
seventy to ninety four K for a handrail
along the western side between the
shared person that the drain or a
barrier is that the case
looks like it in the planner young in
the design there's some sort of bow
lighting system along the full length of
the road preventing wayward cyclists
from tipping into the drain
well what away I would call it a
waterway can you confirm this I'll take
that one if you like Joanne okay thank
you Erin yeah one everyone yes for the
been the recommended design there has
been an allowance made for just the
northern section that's particularly
where the with the existing road and we
were retaining the car parking on the
eastern side pushes the shared path to
be in quite close proximity to the drain
but the rest of the recommended option
so about 3/4 of the length would be far
enough removed from the drain where
there's no barrier required so just
clarified that is that the what the last
section up by McDonald's across the road
from McDonald's that's right yes okay I
can't support and in it's um it's
$94,000 worse no I don't think that
would be 94,000 on the recommended cuz
that very hard to to decipher plane that
I haven't got up at the moment and when
I look down it did have seventy to
ninety four thousand for the barrier
along the western side between the
shared path and the waterway can you
quell can you clarify how much that's
Costin and and another associated
question is there is a proposal for
piping part of the drain so that you can
hear a bus stop it was suggested right
in the early stages of this project that
that that power
Station Reserve right as the there's the
road curves round by or just as a comes
a-huntin line side road there is a huge
big grassy area there by the power
station
why don't you it hasn't the design
utilized that hunk of grass and it's
quite extensive
for a bus stop
why can't would go into that area in
park and put a bus through it and it
would mean that you wouldn't encroach on
you go you'd have an off-road bus stop
if you went straight ahead whether with
a where the kiosk station is on the
corner can someone explain why that
hasn't been taken up so I can probably
talk to that one sander and I think the
issue would be getting the buses in
there that you didn't have to turn them
around and get them back out again and
that would be very difficult and they're
small area to try and turn buses and
maneuver them back out again so well
they do there is why it's Road that goes
straight out into Todd's Road and then
through the dermlite side but then you
run alongside the drain and then
bringing them out very close to another
intersection so I think there would be
some issues from a safety perspective
deal on it one could look good through
the police I'm certainly happy to take
it away and look at it but you say he's
just raising concerns around safety and
could the question about the cost of the
bowl adding be be bought back so it
looks like it was up to ninety four
thousand dollars so I believe that was
for a a galvanized pipe rail rather than
just a ball and chain type and
arrangement and that's why the bit
coordinates but we can certainly come
back that's what the design shows you
the design show
the what looks like a galvanized bollard
yeah so what is the cost in that 1.9
million for this project what is the
cost of the bonding mr. young yes just a
couple of points there just to be clear
the the bus stop is mentioned as a
potential future it's not being built as
part of this work so it's noted that the
bus doesn't go this way anymore and so
and in the process of designing it was
identified that there was a risk that a
future changes were made to the bus
route again that we needed to make sure
we allowed for that so desert there's a
note on the report that potentially
would be eighty to a hundred and twenty
K's if in fact they're eventuated in the
future but really the main point was
just noting that space would be allowed
for a bus stop in the future your
suggestion with regard to the location
of that I think is something we could
certainly look at I would be a little
concerned about the proximity of your
sign to that to the main South Brodeur
line side road but it is worth putting
back on the table but we're not going to
be building anything at this stage with
regard to the cost of the handrails yes
the portion the the recommended option
hasn't allowing some thereof $70,000 the
higher number you referred to was for
one of the other potential options is
what I understand so yes there would be
some money allowed for that northern
portion Fraser or Aaron correct me if
I'm wrong with that assumption that is
correct thank you thank you Donna
so yes the the recommended option
currently has 70,000 allowed for the
section of handrail that would be
required as a a a bespoke I'm sorry I
should say an off-the-shelf product that
was found and sourced but there would be
many alternatives f2 to look at
to clarify that that's that's not our
traditional sort of wooden bollard and
chain that you're talking about Aaron
you're talking about something quite
different at 70 K yes that Street it's a
fall a fall barrier and so it's
certified as a as a follow on handrail
that could have been used on the edge of
a substantial fall the thinking being
that they standard cheap and cheerful
bollard and chain may result in more
risk of if there was a collision of
tripping people up and creating further
risk of heading down into the drain I'll
worry about the cost associated with
with it why can't we just put some more
plants there plenty of Carrick sector
fall into that you'll be fine I'm Paul
sorry I I think they're good and
legitimate question to ask councillor
Stewart regarding the cost of that
barrier I think the EM will definitely
take that away what we're really looking
for here today as a decision from the
utilities and rolling Committee on which
option staff would progress to a
detailed design and as part of
progressing that design we will then
look a lot more at the details like
exactly where we need handrails what
they might cost and that'll be to a
large extent be interlinked with the
safety audit that we carried out so I
suppose very good question and I think
all we can do today as say yes we'll
take those comments on on board but on
whichever option you chose there will be
detailed items like this that we need to
work through as part of a design and we
will be trying to do it as
cost-effectively as possible and also
give it to your safety audit on it and
make it look lovely
thank you can select some council award
in there Mia so Neville Thank You
counselor games number one for me I
don't even know why there's a cycle
walkway there I mean I Drive this three
times a week without fail never seen a
cyclist on that road in the whole time
that I've fair that I've gone down the
other day and the only pedestrians
oversee on that road are the ones that
are crossing from the carpark to go to
McDonald's or to their place of work and
you were gonna remove those car packs
from there so number one I wonder about
the cycleway at all and number two just
to comment on the on the handrail the
order mr. chair is this not time for
questions that is Mike I asked a
question thanking the handrail I want to
know why we're why would we do that we
don't do it on the stop banks of all
their rivers so why would we put one on
the side of a waterway if you like on
the side of a road it doesn't make
logical seeds some of each other answer
that question yes certainly
in terms of cycleways and whether we put
in a cycle way or not this footpads and
cycle an associate cycle paths have been
allowed for in this design and they do
meet the requirements of our walking and
cycling strategy and our district plan
the decision around whether we proceed
with other verses sets with counsel it
is I guess a large area for work in
workers that they are traveling to their
area and we through the consultation
process also got feedback from the likes
of disability services which are down
and Kingsford Smith Drive and they have
major issues with the clients not being
able to walk or cycle down to the
premises so there's certainly a range of
use in the community it is sometimes a
little bit of a chicken and an egg
if you don't provide it then the people
won't use it but if we do then the
appian becomes their option for travel
for people that might not have been
there before
oh my supplementary to that Dean and
then you've almost asked the question
why why encourage people to used one of
the most heavily industrial roads in our
district on a cycle or cycle walkway is
such next to a carriageway
in terms of that we looked at options
for having on road cycle ways but came
to the conclusion and I guess it's
around a couple of factors that helped
influence that one being the space so we
do have limited space down there and
also we are is it safer to put
pedestrians and cycle was in the
conclusion and this case we came to was
she had passed would provide a
reasonable level of service for people
who were wanting to cycle through that
area next having worked down in that
area I think so called out way and she
had cycle way pathway is important and a
safety issue my question would be that
is it really necessary to look at a bus
stop and that corner there because I
don't believe that would be a very safe
option at all I don't think it should
even be considered and that's just my
dear so the reason that was raised is
because they're currently the blue line
goes down flexed and Road and it does
stop at his two stops on one opposite
opposite each other on flex and Road
outside McDonald's so there was a gift
flag for that reason yeah as part of it
recently cane bus network review there
is a proposal to put the buses back onto
line side road so in the future they
won't actually be stopping
on flex turn road so that's the reason
it was flagged as as if it was the case
that the buses moved back to flexin road
for any reason it's just probably
unlikely um Dean the bus stops may be
required somewhere along Lexton road in
India what do you mean D in after the
last burger
amia Thank You mr. Chia my question I
was buffering at the start
during of your presentation there so you
were talking about affected parties you
talked to and you talked to Danielle
Smith I just wondered the heavy sauce
and the additional opinion from the
regulated community board on the abuse I
just must say that if you did mention
that it was that he said this early on
in the process we had gone to the rest
around your Ashley community board with
a number of various options and we did
get mixed feedback around the table
there were I guess some who strongly
supported things like the shared pass
Indian others not so much so definitely
a combination of use around the table
and I think that's also a reflection of
the difficulty there is and trying to
fit it will accommodate all the
different modes of travel within a
reasonably narrow cutting constrained
corridor my client I know noticed I just
oh sorry was just on this current
preferred option here's a view being
sought from the community board at all
this sorry aligns closely to a previous
scheme that had gone in front of them so
I would guess we haven't been back
recently to confirm with them but had
been previously to the board sorry I
just understood that you were I
understood you were going to see
a view from the cheer of the community
born on it is it not being done no I'm
sorry that hasn't happened okay thank
you
and question for myself and for point
nine and option alternative option two
you've got the footpath on the western
side here and eject the only 1.8 instead
of the 2.5 I notice you've got no
handrail on that one there and you've
got a narrow footpath and so that mean
you're only really putting the the
railings money because of cyclist so yes
their option does have a footpath on
both sides of the road rather than a
sheared cycle path on one side she'd
facility on one side and a footpath on
the other so the difference the errors
you've got around 700 millimeters of
additional space that then you can use
or plant differently which is the
difference between whether you need a
handrail off if there are cycles using
that path or not and it's just sorry
just fooled it okay dude which is down
at the McDonald's end of the road the
other is Erin mentioned other around
three-quarters of the road has
sufficient space so it's a section at
the top which is a little bit tighter
and it's due to the parking which is
already on that side of the road as
supplementary to that and so option tow
or turn the box from 4.9 and was there
going to be a week on your grass Luke
there will the straight anthem
a grass verge would become I think a
little bit of a maintenance issue in
terms of trying to keep it tidy and make
it presentable so I think it would be
preferable to plant there and something
that is low maintenance in doesn't hang
out across the footpath or she'd pass
whichever we end up with okay Bonnie
Nick yes thank you very much for this
Joey and it's a good report I've just
got three quick questions initially
there was a report brought to us about a
local business owner providing some
contribution to some Perth can you just
explain that's not mentioned in the
report at all and I just wanted to ask
we did that end up so the contribution
that was proposed originally was for
contribution towards piping the drain
I'm not actually upgrading the road so
was the decision to not pipe the drain I
believe that contribution has has not
happened
thank you and I'm the second questioners
with the shared pathway and well I like
the idea what would stop people parking
on the shared pathway is there any
deterrent we would put no stopping and
down that side of the road in kuben
channel so a vehicle that was wanting to
park on the ax would end up straddling
urban channel it's not I guess
impossible for a vehicle to do and we
would need to monitor there to some
degree just to make sure that it doesn't
happen the other thing I think we would
need is some clear signage that it was a
she had passed so that people didn't try
and park on it but I mean there is a
little bit of an issue with other other
sheet pads around the district is people
not parking on them
sure and the final question is this is
obviously at the high level decision of
the type of person the type of structure
on the road at the stage of actual rails
and plantings and so on will you seek
Graham you're actually community board
input into the and
energy a look of the spark yes and what
we would do is get together and
landscape and proposal we could
definitely bring that back through the
community board Thank You councillor
Edmund Thank You Joanne I had some
communication difficulties so I
apologize in advance if you covered this
but happy
I saw annual report that they were
60-yard car parks being lost on one side
but it didn't say how many were being
lost on the other side at just see it 31
nothing remaining what is the total
number of car parks that will be lost
that's a really good question and they
she don't have that figure on hand I'm
not sure Aaron with Aaron can add
anything to that yes so so I don't have
the exact number directly in front of me
but the recommended option ends up with
about a 75% loss of parking so there's
currently about 60 parks on the east
side that we're reducing down to about
31 just the other thing I would point
out is through the consultation that we
carried out with the businesses we were
given a very very strong steer from the
business community that there was a
desire for the parking on Street
particularly on the western side to go
that it was causing issues and that
there was significant amount of parking
available within the sites particularly
on the western side of the road so it
was very much the flavor of the
consultation feedback that we were
received hmm
supplementary you've also reduced by
possibly 50 per scene the parking that
was to remain I just wondered what
proposals as there to mitigate the loss
of parking since it appears about 90 car
parks
we'll be lost and whenever I go down
there they're all in yours and it seems
a very popular area for parking I'm
assuming they're employees or or
visitors but do you have any plans to
replace some of those packs so I think
not specifically replacing parks so not
providing any off-street parking
the I know one of the businesses at the
northern end has recently constructed an
amount of parking for their staff and
what we have seen an observation is a
higher parking demand at the northern
end of the street and a much reduced
parking demand at at the other end so we
have allowed or I guess tried to
accommodate as much parking on street as
we can at the northern end to be able to
help with their on street parking demand
Thank You councillor Dodi stole my Aziz
just my Christian plays Joe and just
looking at the last page which is a
diagram I've been bad page 31 looking at
the the three varieties here the second
one which has got the parking in a
reduced as they're going to be quite a
lot more expensive to do that one
compared to the first one what just got
you 2.5 she'd and a smaller retained and
- yes it was and that was going to be
significantly over the budget that we
had I'd must doubt on what
next it's it's fine okay so on the third
one the disadvantage of having cyclists
on the road yes definitely
the so the 3.5 metre Lane is I guess a
reasonably standard Lane what's if we
were wanting to cater for cyclists on
road then we would ideally put it be
putting in a 1.6 meter wide cycle lane
on each side of the road which is wider
again and I guess creates quite an
amount more pavement would move the
northbound lanes significantly closer to
the drain which is not a great outcome
thank you and goodbye
can't sleep yeah thank you
guess Williams just doing the issues you
talked about with the parking and
something that's gonna be lost here it's
my understanding that that was around
aesthetics and people driving on the
side of the road was there is that the
issues you're talking about rather than
safety issues of bacne on the west side
we we start of the road
certainly the feedback we got from some
of the businesses on the western side of
the road as they have trouble seeing
when they're coming in and out of the
excess ways and part of it is parked
cars parked right up close to driveways
and I think that was the driver and main
driver behind not having those vehicles
parked along here as well does it help
to open up those sight lines for people
coming in and out of the access ways and
made this improved safety view thank you
can you just remind me and the preferred
option the central median that's a flush
median it's just it's not built up or
anything yeah that's right it's just a
painted median and the middle of the
road and it will help accommodate those
tuning vehicles wanting to go in and out
of the different access ways along the
road thank you aim the mirror I'm just
going to indicate I'm hip u-turn at isla
making a move did you as well yeah well
I would like to move that we go until
terms of option PO 4.9 which everybody
can see in the diagram on page 19 and
and why I think that's what we'll see we
get a movement for that boy a second I'm
sorry what are you moving mr. cheer on -
okay option two which is four point nine
which is the young the one with the one
point eight wide foot path but not shed
psyche away on the western side but
they've got the yam a picture of the
cycleway on the other side so the Rogues
you know reasonably wide I was prepared
to move the original recommendation that
I'm not going to seek in there
we've got no seconder for that okay
we'll move on to so we move on there the
Mears well I'm going to move the
original recommendation but I just like
to put in a just between I and J will
make it J that the regular Ashley
community board be consulted on the
landscaping in the minute here speaks
have you see it mr. Chia and I'm gonna
discussion on us yes
I just just briefly I think the staff
have done a very good job and that's
been a very complicated process trying
to reach
a conclusion with all parties I think is
indicator that had discussion with the
major landowner along Mir who is happy
with what is being proposed there's been
some original conversations with the
community board but picking up
councillor Barnett squish and I think
it's very right that there that they are
consulted on the landscaping and amenity
the factors which pokes up counts the
Stewart's points as well around rails
and other things and just noting that
I'm sure that they would have a a view
on this in particularly cost here speaks
I mean by bridges and other things last
to him being discussed so I think it's
very right that those questions are
raised this is an important project it's
important we get on with this project
that's been long planed and discussed
and as I mentioned I think the staff
have done an excellent job getting us to
this point not painting no not everyone
will be happy with it but I think
they've reached a fair compromise and
must bring up ford here that's the brine
reserve thanks mr. chair okay we've got
cancer strip thank you and I'd certainly
like to support this I thoroughly
supported the shared cycleway walkway on
the western side I use it Road or not
and I think that's a great advantage I
would like to see and the landscaping
down the waterway emits its remover the
word drain from our lexicon here this is
a water course it happens to be spring
fed as well so please alter the report
to reflect it I'd like to see soft
landscaping right the length of the road
and bear in mind that the keep rowing
you're a beautiful has has a real
interest in flexsim Road is an entrance
a major entranceway into ray ora it's
offered trees to go along here and I
would like to think that somewhere along
there too
of 2.5 meters shared past we had the
ability to put in some trees on that
side and I would like to see and I
understand the rationale about this the
central median but I think if there
could be made narrower we could actually
get a better outcome as far as
aesthetics and safety on the on the
shared path that thoroughly support
removing of all the parking along the
western side and the reduction along the
eastern side I go to farm ends all the
time and it's a really dangerous well it
is very difficult to see cars coming
when you're wee bit back I'm going out
those entrance ways so I'd like to see
the aesthetics really ramped up here and
this is an entranceway as I said and
keeping your a beautiful donating trees
around poncey with the idea that the
rest of the road and that becomes an
Avenue entranceway into Ron Yura and
right down to skew bridge so I think a
longer view of the design there and the
factor that you'll you'll have a
cycleway walkway going from skew bridge
through with a hooker joining up from
the oka stream along this road at some
time so we need to have a shared path
and nice aesthetics for an entranceway
to the town thank you yes and I got
myself and then I've got councilor duty
and an in mailings and I'd be opposing
the Sam scenario here money because I
don't think it's safely encouraging
cyclists on this busy busy industrial
zone we've got the community board in
one side of enhancing roadway for
alternative cycle lane which um if we if
we did put the cycling well it will
or use the cycling but we wouldn't be
seen to be encouraging the people to use
it for a cycling name we can hear
impacts of that sound with trains and
including in an ethic and I just think
we have against the station down with
people of trailers doing an ear and what
have you not don't personally I don't
think it's a safe option to encourage
cyclists and in walkers on that
particular stretch of road and the hang
rail I personally prefer some nice wee
trees or straps and all that yummy
instead of a young a handrail but I
think much cheaper and better than maybe
an ugly-looking paying role be on that
side so if we're going to do that I
think would rather have shrubs and some
nice trees and pleasing for the people
rather than an old hen Robert it's just
my acute now we've got councillor duty
thank you I'm very much in favor of us
I'm having gone and used the Hagley your
Peggy Park area as well that she had
pathway down the look works very well
and I like councillor Williams I would
prefer instead of a handrail
so no nice little wee Aging's that
around and flexed and rode that's more
teaching like that little small shrubs
would enhance it much better for the
sake deceitful medians not really
pleased about that
and like countless Stewart I go in and
out or famines about that it's just it's
not an easy one to get into or get out
of so I'm really much in favor of it so
that's that's me okay
oh and got council meetings yeah look I
think that this is a good good solution
and I concur with my colleagues views on
on that the soft edging would be would
be quite good
just from my point of view living in a
hookah like this addresses needs of all
users it's it's a terrible road to walk
on and it's dangerous to cycle so
anything is better than what we've got
right now those that were they were in
the hearing from for the reindeer
attempt plan would have what every
recalled comments on the dangerous
nature of that road for cycling and you
know this this addresses that so I think
it's great move thank you yeah thank you
yes I'll agree with Nicky that it's
dangerous to cycle one but that said iid
who nibbles tubes I can't remember the
last time I saw a cyclist there perhaps
that's because the strangers and they
don't want to be but I just say to the
staff don't go overboard with we're in
your fin Europe and detailed planning
with with either pedestrians or cyclists
because they'll be very few of them on
our shared pathway I support the taking
the through the packing out of there
almost without exception those
businesses have off-road packing I I
Drive there a lot and I shop there a lot
and I can't remember ever packing on the
road to it to go to a business there you
can always get off the road and use
their off-road packing maybe it's a
staff problem with staff packing there
but that best for the businesses to
solve not us so yep I'll support it
castle Bonnie he's that encourage all of
the colleagues on you and I to support
this it's been a long time coming the
community's been asking and asking for
flex and road improvements for as long
as I've been on council and probably
before then it's a terrible Road and the
reason cyclists don't use it is because
it's terrible it's dangerous and so this
opportunity that we've got here to
finally fix it to finally improve this
gateway internal Nora is absolutely
brilliant at the RTC hearing we heard
from a no hoko cyclist who carries her
child and a wagon behind her bike and
her statement was basically that
cyclists will always use the direct path
they don't want to go an extra mile up
the road to Townsend Road to go into an
auto they want to use that The Creeper
so I think it's a case of
builder and they will come this is the
main road from a hookah and Mandeville
which is a growing area in our district
now larger than Oxford so it's actually
essential that we provide means for all
people who are wanting to access from
yura from all Ewa news and the it's also
teaching drivers if they see a shared
path but they need to watch for
pedestrians and cyclists so it's an
education for our drivers to actually be
say well this is a special situation
rather than just a footpath which
they've had in that in the past so I
think it will make it considerably safer
it's an opportunity to improve our
entranceway and if as long as we don't
spend too much money on some of those
aesthetic opportunities we can get the
community involved in actually making it
a really lovely way to come into any
order and I absolutely prod all the work
that's been done on it thank you
that's the brine I think you're not
going to go some good points have been
made but I will say we're not just
building this road for the now we're
building it for the for the future and
in that respect I sincerely hope that
cyclists will be using the shared
footpath and FFA in the future I
frequently sit down there in another
capacity because speeding is an issue on
that on that piece of road and there are
cyclists fewer number at the moment but
build it and hopefully they will use a
probably the most frequent one at the
moment who uses it just about every day
as there's two dogs and as skiers that
the Dickens out of me
of it's a second of dense recommendation
I fully support it and I encourage
colleagues to support it as well thank
you oh we're off you'll apply Nia it's
all been very well said I don't have
anything to achieve all in favor
thumbs up against Kerry right and I
think I'll be no councillor booty and
she can carry on from here
I was quite happy just a setback and you
carry on I've gotta let you do some work
okay
right thank you very much for helping
out I really appreciate it buddy I know
we're going to move on - sorry page 32
which is Jo in with your loading and
transport program please Thank You windy
minimus welcome
now this next report is on our running
capital works and renewals program so we
are seeking approval for the capital
works program for 2020 21 and we have
included the indicative program for
three years following a Cuban Channel
and footpaths renewals and a minor
safety areas have a general allocation
of budget each year and each year we go
through the process of developing a
program to allocate that funding this
report does not cover the large projects
such as park and ride in the Belfast -
choirboy cycleways is there specifically
covered under the LTP our normal
practice would be that we would take
this program of works through the boards
for the input however due to a covert 19
pandemic we've been unable to do that
this year and with the boards not
meeting we have however taken into
consideration feedback that was provided
last year as part of the yes sorry the
process of consulting with the boards
and specifically have added into our
program of works the good Street urban
channel renewal there's the top end and
also William Street between case street
and not Charles Street South Street I
think it was and it was from a specific
feedback which was received from the
wrong you actually end capital here we
community boards the kerbin channel in
footpath renewal programs are generally
predominantly based on condition with
the work being to replace our most
damaged assets first and that is
facilitated through the condition rating
which was carried out every three years
and again this was due to be done
earlier this year but was delayed due to
the cove at nineteen pandemic finally
I'll just point out that our new
footpath rated us our annual past
program has an annual allocation of
$100,000 per year
and that program was developed to
address deficiencies and urban areas we
are the aware streets with no footpaths
we have and sorry and the program was to
allow for a footpath to be installed on
one side of the road on those streets
that had no paths we have a separate
report going to the annual plan a staff
submission report which is suggesting
that this program be put on hold for one
year due to the Cova 19 response and
this has been reflected in the program
which has attached so I'm happy to take
any questions anyone may have any
questions Joey can you just explain to
me that the tram rode off the road of
50,000 what do you plan to do with that
one so there is so we've we've had a we
have had a couple of crashes at the
intersection so what we are planning or
proposing to do is undertake a wee
intersection review for the intersection
and look at how we can do some
improvements to improve the safety view
your number of things going on worse
sorry that was tremor at Oxford
yeah yeah with the business in the work
that happens cutting across the road so
we need to look at how we can be there
delineate through the intersection
because we've had vehicles leaving the
road and in hitting or taking out
signage and fences on the corner of tram
Road
so we'll do undertake away study and
then come back to the Oxford I hope
Community Board on what we're proposing
to do there thank you very much just the
question is learning that there is quite
a right corridor through there and it's
an unusual area because there's some
lumberyard activities which also seem to
take place kind of across the road Thank
You Houston Joanne just I've hit a bit
of feedback again about entrances into
towns particularly Kevin burger eV and
Williams Street coming from Woodend
there's a past walk across that area
there being quite rough if you I
couldn't see them in the program do you
know where they're sitting in terms of
trying to improve our major town
entrances and terms of roading yeah so
with the council injured says there is a
piece of work which Don Young is going
to lead and we will be coordinating
worse and grant MacLeod and the green
spaces team because I guess for each
entrance we need to be clear in have
scoped what work needs to be done and
then how that is funded there is likely
to be some portion of that which will
come from our minor safety program if
there are roadworks associated but then
there will also need to be an allowance
for any landscaping or other type work
which is a green space s beat so we do
have a bit of work ahead of us initially
I think I've got a meeting later this
week
to talk through how we do that and pull
together the plans and a bit of a
timeline for for that work and I guess
each town entrance will potentially be
different and have different
requirements so these yeah there's some
some planning work we need to do to get
that underway but so in terms of
maintenance are you just patching at the
moment because some of those roads seem
a bit rough and I just wondered we they
set in terms of sealing than the program
so roughness and sealing it's not
included in this program and if there's
I can have a chat with you offline just
about any specific concerns let me you
replacing some turbine killing that's
possibly doing it's not that it doesn't
need doing but it as there we have to
balance when kuben channel renewal is
June and when pavement renewal as G so
it doesn't make sense for us to say come
along and do pavement repairs we in two
years later we're going to come along
and do the curb and channel so there are
times when we need to coordinate those
two things which might mean that
something comes forward a year or two
and but we always balance that that's
something that we just have to work
through the other thing is if we know
there are planned works in the area and
we need to coordinate those with other
utility providers or with an even our
own staff within three waters so it's
always a balance that we need to manage
okay
any other questions all right well I'll
move the recommendation please thank you
thank you very much Joe and I'm really
pleased with us I just see that's I just
hope that you can for those out in years
keep the eroding and repairs and
suchlike files and people appears and
there
and line with it because I see this
somewhat that do need to be done but I
appreciate that the timing and the money
is something that has to be balanced out
carefully so thank you very much yeah no
nothing full and I probably bought so on
maybe like okay anybody else like to
speak right I don't need to reply then
I'll just um
all those in favor please say aye or the
thumbs up rose against Kerry thank you
thank you Joe and appreciate that
no just got to find the way here you're
sorry okay cycle cycle and walking my
friends group please sure Joey and again
sorry thank you um this report was
really just for information for
utilities in writing committee but I
guess just to give a very brief overview
as the report went to council and may
confirming the terms of reference for
the walking and cycling group in the
membership additional to the members
noted in this report council nominated
and approved councillor Williams and
councillor Stewart to join us on the
group it is a reasonably big group of
around 27 we are working on the network
plan at the moment this has been or
progress has been slowed slightly due to
Coba 19 and staff working from home
having trouble getting the software to
be able to work efficiently and
effectively so we have staff member back
in the office next week who will be
progressing this further in what we will
now be working through is how
engage with the group under elute level
to Judith sighs so we're just working
through that at the moment I'm happy to
take any specific questions around this
one any questions
these cancel Williams move that we
received report a murder
Thank You counsel
any other discussions would you like to
speak on behalf can say I'm not nothing
it's all straight forward and I think
she didn't need to say about it so okay
[Music]
okay thank you thanks Joanne very much
appreciate it
right now we'll move to and Victor L
beginning of their business ago and we
need to have folio updates please
Counsell Williams
um roading yeah I think we all know
what's happening and there's been a few
hats and pants beam each than the bottle
side and I think Jerry's and look at
them giving us an all the briefing on
the breach enduring of the loading
coming up so I'm a wee bit disappointed
we couldn't have done some of the
writing work while he has on the road
wasn't taking a lot of Road cones away
from it so so nothing else to report on
it okay thank you not much to report in
my portfolio in this this time round
there has been and I think we in the
resource and sense that came through
that we all get there's an application
for a storage dam out in the rural area
that talk you talked about altering a
the stock water race I asked that the
staff have a look at that as far as the
integrity of the stock water erase
system goes and I think they're doing
that so that's about it at the moment
thank you yes yeah and nothing must
report on they hear me to moet and he
straightened properly and I am very
pleased report staff done control very
quickly and and sold the the province
and well hit some discussion with staff
about the soul of this one pair for the
sir station and the station and ring
your're Sitra aimed them following on
with the I think there's a report coming
up to council very shortly about p.m.
the soul appear scenario of costs and
do's and dont's from acute you're on it
so that's about it for this time okay
thank you madam chair as most members
are aware we've got a a solemn hazardous
waste working party meeting scheduled
for 9:00 a.m.
next Monday so I won't go into too much
detail but what I won't do what to save
for the purposes of the of the minutes
is how much I appreciate the fantastic
efforts that kitty a nice Jared and our
contractors although I prefer the term
partners waste management have made over
the last six or so weeks during
incredibly difficult in challenging at
times to keep this essential business
running as well as they have as as just
beyond we
so I'm not going to say say too much but
I thoroughly take my head off to all
concern and keeping that essential
service to our district running as well
as they managed thank you madam chair
just a question please can't spray when
you see it's nine o'clock there's a
another copper a twenty five well my
understanding was was nine but it might
be they're linking in with the the zone
yeah and there isn't it there is an
agenda and formulation it made may be at
an email I don't know thank you
transport mister me opposed thank you
madam chair and thoroughly endorse
councillor Brian's last remarks
excellent work in that space thanks for
those remarks Robbie it's well deserved
to their team just in terms of
transports actually been despite being
in lockdown that's been quite a busy
period of time we've meat by zoom with
the Regional Transport Committee and
also the passenger transport committee
there's been a number of briefings
particularly on the new committee and
see new committees and ceiling
priorities in that space obviously we
made a submission on behalf of Council
to on express buses and in a number of
conversations with respect to me but
with respect of me as the chair of a
keen and I've briefed you on those
earlier I was invited to also join in
the Environment Canterbury working party
on passenger treatable future of peace
nutrients well noted she is some
reservations about joining another body
when we have I respect the current
structures that we've gone in place that
did lead to a discussion on the
efficiency of on the various structures
and in whether there's a better way of
working in this area so it's currently
being considered by respective see
to see if there is a perhaps have been a
way of us working together in that space
it's a little bit more efficient but I
just like to particularly acknowledge
the support of both jurors and Joey to
me it's it's a big area transport
looking at the the not only our
district's perspective but also our
involvement and Greater Christchurch in
the wider Canterbury area as part of the
partnership and in keeping abreast of
all the various nuances I do appreciate
the staff keeping me up to date with it
so I'm representing this council I'm
well briefed and supported for the
broader picture so thanks for that
Thank You detective questions Williams
do you know about this new services
operating around Caston Oxford yes I
think you all an email the other day I
which I hope you got which with Reid bus
suddenly removing the service I was
approached by a number of concern
ratepayers at which point I put a call
into the sea of red bus to see if there
was any option opportunity of that being
reviewed and in there wasn't effectively
we also had conversations with iki and
around service delivery and they they
expressed an interest of potentially
offering a service out there but that
would require a consultation in
consequential rating which I'm sure
given the current climate wouldn't be
broadly well there would be a fair
amount of concern about they'd and we
have had discussions with that community
here in the past and they didn't seem to
be support for that so we have as a
consequence of that there has been three
arrangements that have come about one
being the little blue bus company which
provide transport for school students
effectively they have extended the
service
they're offering a service now from
Oxford that connects the students on the
way through cust but they're restricted
in terms of the service delivery for
four numbers on it to only being a
ministry to type through the ministry
they can use the earth available it will
be a licensing and the ability to extend
that the the distance and requirements
if they abide by the ministry's rules
the year so it's only limited to
students to go on the on that service
which takes the kid that the students
through the respective schools in
Christchurch another individual here's
set up through done and dusted his
pictures to veins as I understand and
we'll be delivering a similar service
and what was previously provided by
rebus that's what's been indicated on
Facebook and a phone call that was put
to me the other day in Oxford community
service of also support have also been
involved they will continue to offer the
current weekly trip to renderer for
those that would like to come down here
and also for respective medical
appointments so through those three
bodies or three responses the community
appears to be covered will be at the
cost there is a an additional cost than
what was previously indicated by read
bus but I'm I guess we can be thankful
that others have stepped up to offer
support through that time it it was very
sudden the read bus announcement in
disappointing but it's just in that if
you read in the paper of all their
challenges with read bus you'll
appreciate that offering a private
service and that's what it was to Oxford
us at least to be concerned recently I
would have liked it to have been at the
forefront but it's just me with the
district hit on just a question it's
what they've indicated on Facebook
in and I had a very brief conversation
the other day that they are indicating
they do that and they're looking to
start that on the 25th as I understand
it's what they'd indicated through their
Facebook thank you anybody else was to
speak right any questions the urgent
general business our next meeting will
be on the 4 p.m. on the 21st of July and
the council chambers so this looks like
this might be our last was a meeting the
fire utilities in writing that makes you
quite enjoying these dimensions of the
truthful so thank you right I'll call
the meeting to close and we've got a
briefing oh I see everybody's getting
all revved up I've got a briefing and
following things and Joey thank you so
we're closing them anything yet five
million thank you
you
[Music]